go ahead and important information that
we can help to get out there so
hopefully we can awake him some good
hearts and some noise can be made some
awareness and I think our friend Joe
Rogan has a great platform I know you've
been on the Jill Rogan show before are
there any plans to return has he invited
you back I mean he's someone that can
can help to spread some of this good
information out there what do you think
yeah mostly center right and he he
sympathizes we you know his emotes he's
a he's a close friend of some like sam
harris he was a close friend with and
his surname eludes me it'll come to me
in a second but he's a number of he
hangs out with islam he sympathizes
we've rectory he brings them on in every
challenge isn't about their their you
know beliefs as far as his on being a
threat to wit and democratic values he
subscribes that kind of thinking so to
be honest i don't think he's really
interested in hearing at camp viewpoint
or people that challenge you know that
was erroneous beliefs I think he's
mighty mind up on Islam and Muslims and
and that's our did you see yourself kind
of there were you there in that same
pocket being influenced by the same
people you came out from that do you
think there's hope that possibly he can
also you know from a different point of
view though I mean I was never in it I
mean I belong while living in the
world's Muslim there world's most
populous Muslim country Indonesia I
lived there for a decade and I was fine
with Islam and I was fine with Muslims I
love you know France or Muslim witness
in a terrorist attack almost
specifically to my original Maya in 2005
on jooveron Beach where a dozen people
were killed
basically my friends and I were
effectively first responders we had to
run the application you know you know to
determine it was a lot of it was dead
and bring the wounded front of the beige
Hartman to me by roadway now that don't
mean for this long foe because I became
obsessed would have what happen it with
that no obviously because double the
cream on my way through it a needle
degree of terrorism but you know you
better back that short period my life
from 2005 to about 2009 I did subscribe
to the fact that a bigoted beliefs which
was espoused by the same Harrison
Richard Dawkins and alike in two
critical missions but then when I pulled
myself out of the book by researching
Islam and I did that on my own because I
wrote a book on the Koran and row
talking about the life of the Prophet
Mohammed was only when I didn't
researcher his life I did I understand
how Islamophobes
and Islamic extremists locally Laden or
bang daddy did contextualize the Quran
in a way which is totally inconsistent
with what Muhammad meant and you can
understand what the prophet prophet
prophet Muhammad meant when you
understand he was biography and he's
life and where he was at any given point
in his life so you know it was his line
which depended from his love of Fogle's
Islam which sure brought me out of it
Joe Rogan right now we'll get him this
direct message God willing and now
you're sitting across from which guests
can you picture in your mind on the Jill
Rogan show if he if he when he hears
this to set it up who would it be
you're ready to go you get the call
you're ready to come back on and
challenge some of those falsehoods
doesn't matter it doesn't matter anyone
he picks Sam okay CJ we appreciate the
wonderful work you're doing thank you so
much how can people now if they want to
follow some of your work you have a
podcast also
tell us about that yeah sure the best
way to follow me is on Twitter at CJ
Wellman that CJ wer le MA in and I have
a podcast called
you know which is channel the rage you
can find that on iTunes we've now got
about 54 55 episodes are the whole
purpose of the podcast is to to give a
voice to the voiceless
or rather Muslim victims of the global
war on terror and discrimination you
know we we have guests who keep dialing
for Muslims from India Muslims from
Myanmar Muslims from you know what we
get Muslim refugees had a number of
those guys on so yeah it's it's trying
to reveal what's happening around the
world and you know stories about Muslims
that you know Western media refuses to
tell keep speaking truth thank you very
much it's a very nice an honor to have
you back on the program God willing
we'll we'll meet again soon sometime
thank you very much CJ for being with us
here on the Deen show we really
appreciate you speaking the truth and
being out there on the forefront
creating awareness and we just got to
hear some very sad news it reminds us
that holding on to this Deen will be
like holding on to the hot coals as it's
been stated and you see that the people
who have been made to look like those
who are causing terrorism havoc on the
lands are the people who are the most
oppressed the Muslims and as CJ wheeler
Minh confirmed in academic circles
counter-terrorists academics all confirm
there's nobody in this area of expertise
that will come out and say that Islam is
the cause of terrorism Muslims are the
growing threat to this country this is
as he said this is fiction this is false
so you but you do have a true narrative
that's out there people who are trying
to create dissension through fear
through your ignorance so make sure that
you get informed on what Islam is what
Muslims are all about here at the Deen
show send us your questions we have a
live chat box we have a phone number 1
800 662 Islam in this day and age of
misinformation you got to be careful
what you're looking for you know they'll
attack you you go out there looking for
hate you're gonna find it and then those
cookies that they have they're going to
keep sending you more and more but you
have to make a commitment within
yourself I want to know the truth I'm
gonna be what genuine and sincere in
that quest for the truth because the
truth shall set you free and it's out
there but if you're already angry and
you're bitter you're not happy in life
and you go down that path of seeking
misinformation and following people out
there who are spreading misinformation
it's not going to help you feel any
better so be genuine be sincere in your
quest to want to know the truth
we're here to help you call us visit us
subscribe to the Dee's show click on the
notifications tab so you can be informed
when our next show comes out and we hope
that you make that genuine attempt to
learn really what Islam is about what
Muslims are about keep visiting us thank
you very much we'll see you next time
here on the deed show peace be with you
Islamic please subscribe to the D show
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]